So welcome Jeremy, thank you for
coming in and talking to us.
>> Of course,
I can't wait to see what you've got.
>> Yeah, so
what we've got here is essentially,
a to do list, slash calendar app.
And I'd just like you to take a look
at this, and try to make a new event.
Sorry, a new task.
>> Okay, so looking at the homepage,
I see I've got this sign in button, so
that's a nice different color,
very obvious.
Let me hit it.
All right, so now I'm in the main
screen of the application and
I see I've got this
big button right here.
So I bet that creates a new task.
All right I've got a new untitled task,
see if I can get a name, or is this
the prototype the text fields are-
>> Yes,
the text fields aren't
working right now.
I can see you want to
be able to use them you
want to be able to type in things.
>> So, I want to click through
all of these and then,
hit the big create button.
>> Yep, awesome.
>> Okay.
>> So, you've made a new event.
That's awesome.
>> That was very clear.
>> Now, can you just sort of
navigate through the app.
See if there's anything that makes
sense to you as an extra feature.
See if there's anything
that you want to explore.
How would you go about
exploring this app, first off?
>> Well, let me just scroll down,
all right.
So I've got my list of tasks,
there's nothing else down there.
Let me see if I can move back and
forth through the days,
I presume in the full
app that would work.
>> In the full app that would work,
but right now we don't have that?
>> Well the only other thing that I see
to explore is this menu button up at
the top, so let's see what we've got.
Okay, we have a bunch of different
options, should I just pick one or?
>> Yeah, sure,
just explore a little bit.
One thing that I want to see especially,
is your reactions to certain of these
pages, so you know the overview page,
the calendar pages.
>> Well let's check out
the overview page first.
>> Okay, so I have this list of,
I assume these are different collections
of tasks that I've done
stuff with in the past.
And then some graph of I guess,
how often I've used things,
how often I've completed things.
>> Would this be a useful thing to
use as somebody who's going to use
to do apps?
>> Not really, I don't particularly
care about when I completed tasks,
I just want to look at my current
list of tasks that I have to do.
>> Awesome, so can you go back and
find your current list of tasks?
So, I think Home,
probably take me there.
Yeah, so
this is everything I needed to do today.
This is kind of my primary
mode of interaction
with a to do list app, I think.
>> Perfect.
And if you wanted to check off a task,
say you finished your
meeting with Jacqueline,
how would you go about doing that?
>> Well, it looks like
there's this big empty box,
which I imagine is a check box.
>> Okay.
Yeah, and in the final app,
when you click that, that would check
off and something would happen there.
What would you expect to happen
when you hit that check box?
>> I would imagine that it would just
kind of like animate out of the list and
other events would slide up and
slide into place.
>> Awesome, thank you.
So you've given us great feedback.
I appreciate your time.
>> Absolutely, this was fun.
>> Perfect, thank you Jeremy.